uh look okay russell wilson's there
that's good
guy they gave up two first-round picks
to acquire from the jets
last year isn't present it was initially
reported and presented
as a hold out pete carroll later
explained that
jamal adams absence is excused we'll
talk more about that in a second for now
let's hear some of what carol had to say
yesterday about
the fact that jamal adams is not present
at the mandatory mini camp
what jamal is there anything you can
tell us about this state of contract
talks with jamal
not really really we're it's been
ongoing and and that's
been amicable throughout um
you know we we recognize that he's a
fantastic football player
and and and we're in the midst of a you
know it's a big contract
um process um but he's been
i know he knows he's been treated with a
lot of respect and and he's been very
respectful towards the club as well
been they've been good talks and and uh
just hasn't been able to get settled at
this point but
um it's coming we expect we expect them
for camp and everything should be fine
yeah you know here's why it's coming
because they did the trade without
getting a deal done
yeah i don't know when this became an
acceptable trend in the end i thought
well i know when
it's not acceptable in my view don't ask
me i don't know what the hell i'm
talking about but i know this
if i'm going to give out multiple
first-round picks for laramie tunsil
or for jalen ramsey or for jamal adams
you
you trying not to curse here you bet
your ass i'm good that i get that that's
acceptable
you bet your ass i'm getting him signed
to a new contract on the way through the
door what the hell are these people
thinking
what what was bill o'brien thinking what
was less sneed and sean mcvay thinking
what would john schneider and pete
carroll think you're gonna do this trade
and not get inside you give him all the
power
all the leverage because you have to
sign him now
he's your s he he's your to not your one
first round pick
like the cowboys with amari cooper and
they were over a barrel with him and
paid him 20 million a year
you give up two first round picks for
this guy of course you're going to give
him what he wants
you've given him all the power and uh
i i don't get it and i hope it doesn't
continue just because it's happened
three times
because it makes no sense to me one time
well i i know but i in my i think it's
going to continue to happen with these
cal these type of players these caliber
players we're talking about like the
cream of the crop
i mean it's it's the best players in the
game to where i think you know a lot of
these teams are
yeah it does seem crazy i'm with you but
it seems to all work out in the end for
both sides to where they never seem to
be
like really disappointed and i think
like for more times than not
the teams know what they're getting into
and are just willing to like do it
and kind of buy their time figure out
their team
figure out you know the salary cap and
what needs to be done and okay now it's
finally like the time we gotta do it
let's all right we got our ducks in a
row let's try to figure it out now i
mean you're right jamal adams has
tremendous leverage here in this
situation because of the trade
because of the defensive scheme they run
like we've talked about
he is cam chancellor of that scheme
except he's more talented than cam
chancellor and i don't say that lightly
because i think cam chancellor is the
freaking
man one of the most underrated safeties
in the history of football for my money
but like jamal adams as you heard myself
or rodney say last year
he's a hall of fame caliber talent
you know no matter what and last year
wasn't his best year
you know he he missed messed up and i
think he'd be the first one to tell you
that learning the new scheme and all
that
i think both of us can sit here with a
straight face
and go if we had a draft of the 10 best
defensive players in football
jamal adams is definitely going in the
ten the top ten
i think i mean maybe maybe top five but
definitely top ten
at least in my opinion and that's why i
just think
it all gets done and and they know how
valuable he is
jayla ramsay got 20 million a year when
he finally did his contract larry
thompson got 22 million a year both guys
blew the curve yeah set new high water
marks at their positions it's easier to
do that
when you have that leverage because
think about it when you're dealing with
a guy
who is unhappy and wants out and and i
don't know that this applied to tunsil
as much as it applied to ramsey and
adams it definitely applies to ramsey
and adams
these guys wanted out of where they were
yeah
that's the time to get them to agree to
more favorable contract that's true
not once they've settled in and accepted
the fact hey you've given up the farm to
get me
now now you you can't you can't let me
leave you'll look like idiots
if you give up two first-round picks and
then you have to franchise tag me or i
eventually walk away so
you get the guy to take the deal you
wanted to take
as a condition of getting the trade done
and you're more likely to get
a deal that that works for you over the
long haul and chris as it relates to the
notion
that jamal adams is excused right from
mid camp the seahawks know they got to
tread lightly with this guy
right he's he's feisty he's fiery they
dealt with that with the jets it's one
of the reasons why they traded him
great player we can't handle him right
we don't know how to handle them
nothing makes the guy happy so i think
that carol doesn't want to be
in the same spot the jets were when you
you've broken the relationship and the
guy just wants out yeah
and that's the risk you take when you
give up two first round picks to trade
for a jalen ramsey or jamal adam the
guys who made it clear that they were
done where they were you step
into the shoes of the team
with which those guys decided they were
done and they may be done with you at
some point that's a risk you have to
take
you have to you can't ignore that and i
think the seahawks
i think the big reason i think the only
reason why his absence is excused is
he made it clear he's not doing anything
until he gets paid
and they understand the last thing we
want to do is antagonize jamal adams by
making him pay us 93 000 dollars by
calling it
an unexcused absence yeah no a hundred
percent you know and and you're right i
mean they
they roll out the red carpet for guys
like this jalen ramsey
jamal adams whatever deandre hopkins
once they make the trade i mean i think
they're
they know what they've gotten themselves
into certainly
but they believe in the talent and
they've more times than not i think done
their research on the personality a
little bit to go wait we think we can
make this work and do that
but like both those teams like the rams
and seahawks when they made those trades
were not necessarily in like the best
salary cap situation so
that's where they got to buy their time
too that's what happens when you have a
team that's a
you know full of high-end talent um so
yeah they're going to tread lightly
but we know by the way the year ended
last year and some of those press
conferences
and hey jamal adams was playing hurt
with a hurt shoulder
on that contract he certainly could have
sat out and gone nah
it hurts i didn't get a new contract it
still hurts
he could have done that you know but he
gave us press conferences where i'm in
the playoffs i love this
this is amazing we're winning i mean i
don't think he could be happier with the
cult
culture he's in he just got to get paid
and i understand that because we've
talked about this
his dad was a star
and got hurt and never got paid so he's
scarred by that
and then the last thing is just like we
we showed the graphic there
come on he's not even the top paid
safety on his own team quandary diggs is
making more money than him
and there's a lot of people above him
that are not in his class that he's
going okay it's time i gotta get paid i
play this game like a psycho
i throw my body around i'm better than
justin simmons and buddha baker and
that's no disrespect to them because
they're awesome
but he's better and i would think that
he gets a significant
bump from what justin simmons fifteen
two five
two five deal is i'm thinking jamal gets
like 17
something like that and kind of does
semi blow the doors off the market like
you're talking about mike
well look he's gonna get what he wants
yeah because they
signed on the dotted line when they
traded for him and they get the whole
package and this guy's
fire and intensity spills over beyond
the field and you got to know how to
manage him and pete carroll has managed
a lot of difficult personalities over
the years and i'm not selling short his
ability to do so
he proved yesterday that he knows how to
do it by downplaying everything and
they're not going to
find jamal adams they're going to let
him not be there at one point carol said
well you know he was injured anyway it's
not like he could do anything but he can
still be there
he can still be there with his teammates
but he's not there because i think he's
made it clear
he ain't showing up for anything until
he gets that 17
million or more per year hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports